hello and welcome back to another
episode of Face Off I'm Ben Davies and I
will be the guy who reads the cards
today for the current champion show that
current champion is of course
nullstradamus himself Mr Michael Knowles
it's wonderful to be with you thank you
for having me on my own show this topic
is near and dear to my heart so I'm I'm
really really looking forward to getting
started and this is a very special
episode because today is the first ever
rematch after we found out definitively
that he was in fact a worse Catholic
than Michael Knowles and that man who
needs no introduction the sweet baby
gang's daddy himself man that hurt to
say Mr Matt Walsh
um yes I uh I continue to to insist that
if people are going to call me Sweet
Daddy just do it in written forms I
don't like to hear it said out loud but
I listen I'm a woman everyone knows I'm
a women's study scholar now so this is
uh I I feel pretty prepared might be a
bad Catholic but uh when it comes to
women's studies I I'm the preeminent
scholar in the world so I'm feeling
pretty good well well in honor of the
greatest documentary film ever what is a
woman available now exclusively at the
daily wire and given Michael's hot
streak I felt like it would only be
fitting to step into Matt Walsh's area
of expertise and put his research to the
test to find out once and for all who
knows more about the opposite sex this
is Face-Off women Edition
Michael I believe you have something
you'd like to say I absolutely do when
you're doing your own research into
women and people of the opposite sex you
probably don't want people looking at
your internet data which is why you've
got to check out expressvpn go check out
expressvpn today smoothest ad segue ever
that was definitely one of your best
Michael
all right here we go first question what
is the highest number of children that a
single woman has ever birthed
what is the record that a single woman
as in an unmarried woman no no just a
woman like one woman the most children
ever birth over the course of her life
of the course of her life yes not all at
once
oh okay all right
um
all right all right Knowles
30. Walsh I'm gonna say 23.
the correct answer gentlemen is an
impressive 69 children oh no way nice
really that's crazy that's not possible
to a woman who she's the wife of Fedor
this law fed some Russian guy oh yeah
sure him she gave birth to 16 pairs of
twins seven sets of triplets and four
sets of quadruplets when was this what
what year was it this is between 1707
and 17 and 82. there's no way to confirm
that's actually true I don't I don't I
need proof before I accept that I
actually lost that they do say that the
first 67 or the hardest and then after
that it's pretty easy actually all right
Point goes to Michael Knowles that I was
with you guys I thought it was like
around 20. that was that was ridiculous
all right
what is the most female dominated
profession in America
um
like Elite legal professions
yeah like job career
make sure Wallace doesn't get his phone
out
hey Siri what's the most female
dominated profession
what's the most female dominated
profession check it out you better write
down your answer first she didn't she
didn't give an answer at all oh if you
wait a second I just this one's a
toss-up there's you know there's three
or four that a lot of people go to
Michael what was yours HR HR that's a
good one Matt Walsh what I thought of uh
in a moment of inspiration was a
preschool teacher preschool teacher it
is in fact preschool teacher wow what
are the odds
did you I education is a passion of mine
so I know a lot about that field 97.6
wow yep
imagine the 2.4 percent
all right next question what does the
average woman spend on makeup per year
the average woman spend on makeup per
year the average American woman yes
so really both of us are just answering
what we think our wives spend yeah
that's all this really is yeah
50 000 no at least actually does not
wear a lot of makeup all right we're
gonna go Matt Walsh first
three thousand dollars I I had put it in
a much more modest six hundred dollars
the average woman spends thirteen
hundred eighty dollars per year is that
that's closer right now we're talking I
didn't even need Siri I'm not good with
math but I think Michael just got a
point there Mrs Walsh just Rob and Matt
blind and those Cosmetics all right next
up
who was the fastest woman ever
who yes she has the world record in the
100 meter dash
that guy from the Connecticut High
School
I assume this
uh I just got to write a random woman's
name down and uh
all right Matt Walsh
um the well-known Olympian Mary Smith
is the fastest woman Michael Knowles uh
I said Amelia Earhart
ah that would be good this is the 100
meter dash though this is Flo Joe
Florence Joyner in the 80s she ran 10.49
in 100 meter dash and fun facts if I
identified as a woman I would be the
second fastest woman ever wow you what
you wouldn't be the fastest woman ever
no that she was Juiced out of her mind
allegedly she was this no one's even
gotten close to This Woman's 100 meter
dash world record Flo Joe that was my
second guess yep okay
all right how much more time does it
take for the average woman to park a car
more time above What It Takes the
average man yes do you want the answer
in minutes or hours
yeah the study's actually still going
they're still trying to parallel park
somewhere
hmm
all right Mike what you got I'm gonna
say 90 seconds
Matt Walsh what's exactly what I wrote
really oh no
it is actually 20 seconds according to a
female lead study 20 seconds every time
female lead study yeah yeah next up what
is the average height of a woman in
America
it's about to increase substantially I
think in the next few years but
depending on how we classify things
all right Matt you were a woman scholar
what you got Matt Walsh
five six I said five four
according to World data the average
height of an American woman is 5'4 yes
son of a man how could how this doesn't
make any sense um there's something
going on here the tallest women in the
world are actually from Latvia and the
average is five six and like three
quarters so Americans are shorter on
average now no you know what this is
also just because Matt's built like a
lumberjack so to him he's just like oh
yeah I know what's the average height
for a world like five eleven everyone
under six feet tall is like the same
height in my opinion so all right
how many types of bras not Brands just
types of bras are there
tight there's more than one type right
it's like push-up
regular
I've got two they're shockingly more
than you would expect I would I would
get I would have guessed two if you
hadn't led us into the question that way
black red yeah
off on hmm
uh
the kind where you do this spot and the
you know and then some that's you know
uh 15 seconds
types
I'm ready to go start humming that music
Walsh I'm ready
all right all right Mike what do you got
I said 15 because you said the number
15. when you said how much time we had
left and that's what put it in my head
and I also said 15. are you kidding me
the answer is
flashy five 45 different types of bras
can you list them all well because
obviously there's some for two some for
three nothing for seven it's no it's not
even oh no
all right next up according to Rancor
the website the open source ranking
website who is currently the most
attractive woman in the world
but now you're really going to get us in
trouble yeah this is bad this is what
other people are ranking you know what
other people think yes this is an
updated ranking system all the times
this would be the current most
attractive people in the world I don't
know because I'm also not really into
pop culture so I don't even I don't even
really know who the hot chicks are I
know who the hot chicks are from like 15
years ago yeah I'm gonna give an answer
from like the early 90s yeah uh Cindy
Crawford yeah like Queen Elizabeth
she used to be back in her day
uh Matt Walsh
I put
um Hillary Clinton
might just be a personal taste thing I
don't know
I I put two answers I said for the rank
or answer Kate Moss but in reality my
wife ah you get bonus points you didn't
get any points for the answer though
okay well yeah I'll take what I can get
who was it currently the hottest woman
in the world is Gal Gadot from one woman
and second is Scarlett Johansson
um and third by the way Caitlyn Jenner
did you would you have guessed that is
it the person the person closest gets
the point right so who's closer to Gal
Gadot not for this Hillary Clinton or
Kmart
all right next up what number of sexual
partners does the average woman have in
her lifetime and this is a study done in
the United States and UK
this is an anonymous study we assume
yeah yeah
it was a study with over 2 000 people
what a hussy 2 000 people that girl
that's bad
number of sexual partners yes sexual
partners and not not business partners
and this was uh people who identify as
women actually is what they said oh
people ident well now you've just I just
don't know anything there's none that
just say women anymore they're all
identified which is why people need to
go watch what is a woman available now
exclusively the daily wire
all right
um
I don't know everyone's such a [ __ ]
these days it's hard to know
cut out that I said that cut out the
these days yeah
all right
um okay all right
Michael Knowles I said
six now Walsh I'm gonna be a little more
generous and say four
the correct answer is seven
seven and guess what the hell ladies
guess what the average number for a man
is in his lifetime
doesn't
6.2 it's lower than the average woman
now that's shameful
yep wow let me ask you something what if
there was someone out there who kept a
log of every single thing you ever did
every minute of the day that would
probably be pretty creepy right but what
if I told you that already happens it
happens every time you go online your
internet provider ATT Comcast whatever
they are allowed to store logs of every
website you've ever visited they can
legally sell this data to anyone which
is why you got to use expressvpn
expressvpn reroutes your internet
connection through their secure servers
so that your internet provider cannot
see or log what you do online this is so
important especially if you're like me
maybe you're not the most politically
correct guy in the world maybe the power
is the B probably don't love what you
have to say all that much it's so easy I
put expressvpn on my phone on my
computer boom boom click a button I'm
online I don't need to worry about it
stop letting people keep logs of what
you do online visit expressvpn.com
Michael YT right now find out how you
can get three months for free next
question do women find a photo of a man
smiling or straight-faced more
attractive
do women find a photo of a man smiling
or straight faced more attractive
for my sake I hope it's straight-faced
yeah
I could see psychobabble going in either
direction on this one
all right Mike what do you got I say
smiling boss
and as predicted I'm going to say
straight faced
research
research has shown
that has wait research has shown fine
Richards is Ben this is Ben having a
stroke I'm gonna summarize this uh
research has shown that women find the
first ex that they find the this is
amazing can we get Cabot back here
where's cabin all right research has
shown that women find the first
impression most attractive when the man
is brooding and mysterious wow that's me
brooding in the serious here's my
question about that though there was a
great essay written by Chris Hitchens
some years ago called why women aren't
funny
and one he he said that there were
exceptions for why women aren't funny
including if they are Hefty or lesbians
or Jewish but he said generally women
aren't that funny and his his argument
was because they don't need to be
because men find women really physically
attractive whereas men have to be funny
because we're not generally very
physically attractive so I would expect
I don't know I would expect a sense of
humor to
all right according to Forbes how much
money did Mackenzie Scott get in her
divorce with Jeff Bezos
uh I don't know gosh
this also makes her the second
wealthiest woman on the planet
second wealthiest all right so
all right all right Matt
five billion
Michael
100 billion
it is
57.7 billion so I thank Michael barely
squeezed out that sucks that was
extraordinarily close wow all right all
right what do most women notice first
when meeting a man
hmm like what captivates the woman
physically
or you'll be more specific spiritually
like is it a personality trait a
physical trait it I can't specify
according to who
according to women in this fall
in what Paul
does he running at the clock here it's
going who conducted the poll ten seconds
I don't have the article in front of me
I think I know the answer the whole
thing's rigged you just brought me on
here to embarrass me while I'm promoting
my film
that's what this is about
what's in that mug
don't worry about that
all right you guys got it I think so all
right Mike what do you got I'm gonna say
height yes that's what I said
you guys are both dead wrong apparently
it's the eyes oh please
ask this question to uh some of the
women in the makeup room and everyone
said eyes immediately that was like the
thing that's so fake that's just that's
just how they view themselves the actual
answer is a height money I don't know
car maybe nobody cares about anybody's
eyes I don't even when someone says oh
they have nice looking eyes I don't know
what that means everyone's eyes look the
same yeah all right name five countries
with the highest proportion of women in
parliaments name five and you'll get a
point for each one you get correct
I'm gonna get every single one of these
wrong
I'll give you a hint it's not Pakistan
okay that was one of my first answer
some of these are hard for me to
pronounce
and if I hear a hey Siri you're
automatically disqualified yeah no I
think all right I've got my answers all
right
Matt you good yeah all right Michael I
said Estonia Finland Iceland the UK and
then when you gave your hint at the end
I said here's your stand
it was known for their feminism I said
USA Brazil Canada and some places in
Europe
the top five are Rwanda at 63.8 percent
which is why Honda Rwanda and Dora with
50 Cuba at 48.9 Sweden at 45 I thought
you guys may get Sweden and South Africa
at 44.8 so we got none of us got
anything answers right no what about
cures you stand uh I don't think that's
gonna fly with the uh fact Checkers here
didn't realize Cuba had much of a
parliamentary system kind of Nora yeah
that was my that's what I was good at
yeah all right next up what is your
wife's favorite color
am I married to like a four-year-old
what do you mean favorite color people
do adults have favorite colors I got
confirmation from both your wives this
morning of what these colors are
marriages are riding on this yeah all
right I got I gotta guess all right boss
what do you have hey Siri what's my what
uh
maroon why would you pick such a
specific shade of a color I picked red
generally you guys both got it right
actually red and maroon she said maroon
she said maroon I know my wife wow okay
well even though Matt just got
absolutely destroyed and lost he did
kind of win there at the end that's
impressive how much is the last question
worth because you know it could be worth
seven or eight which is not just a
specific answer the fact that I knew my
wife that well I feel like that should
be worth something oh the winner and
still king of Face-Off Michael Knowles
and To the victor goes the spoils so
Matt Walsh do you have anything you'd
like to say about the Michael Knowles
show
what is it supposed to be 30 seconds
yeah
well you know Michael Knowles along with
having a great podcast also is a great
author of the book reasons to vote for
Democrats so my pitch for his show will
be in the spirit of that wonderful book
[Music]
wow Matt that was
that moved me Michael did it move you it
did thank you very much Matt that was uh
really succinct concise speaking your
language I thought you're speaking my
language a true economy of words I'm I'm
glad that we could delve a little more
into uh what women are what women want
you know you take a man you take away
accountability and reason as Jack
Nicholson once said I'm glad that we
could uh get to know the opposite sex
they say there will never be a gender
War because everyone is Sleeping with
the Enemy and to follow this up in a
spirit of true a gracious Victory here I
think I'm gonna go watch what is a woman
well there you have it if you haven't
seen it already go check out what is a
woman right now over at the daily wire
and please write in the comments section
and let us know who you'd like to see
and what topic you'd want them to cover
in the next episode of Face Off
[Music]
[Music]